bennett höher die recht nein das ist
meine türen im namen es ist ein problem
du hast recht das ist deine tür
hast du ein paar böse jungs unter der
tür ja fast & furious jobcenter die
neunte folge die wir sehr erfolgreichen
action komödie
und jemand erwartet eigentlich was
völlig anderes als das was dann
letztlich zu sehen ist weil die zeit der
getunten autos scheint vorbei zu sein
man sieht nur noch sehr wenig
verfolgungsjagten stattdessen fokussiert
sich der ganze film so ein bisschen mehr
auf den nahkampf und das schöne ist dass
es eine sehr coole helden gibt alexa
kirby spiel tief und die krempelt die
ganze handlung so ein bisschen umsonst
vielleicht mach dir das was ich vermute
überlebenschance 60 40
naja 2001 kam der erste film raus und da
ging es eben um junge männer die voller
begeisterung ihre autos tunen und sich
irgendwelche illegalen autorennen
liefern das was wir jetzt zu sehen
bekommen ist ins bin wenn wir drei nicht
zusammenarbeiten sterben der jahn
menschen die beiden hauptcharaktere
hawks im tor sind wir werden von johnson
und jason statham in den vergangenen
folgen von fast and furious immer mal
wieder aufgetreten sind aber eher so
nebencharaktere und werden jetzt eben in
den mittelpunkt gerückt die beiden
kommen eigentlich am anfang überhaupt
nicht mehr klar und wollen auch nicht
zusammenarbeit nun wie es gibt dann eben
einen ziemlich machtvollen antagonisten
rixen heißt ja ich würde praktisch in
eine killermaschine verwandelt den haben
die zusagen aufgeschnitten und ihn so
machtvollen entwickelt das man nicht so
leicht gegen den ankommt das heißt sie
müssen zusammen kämpfen gegen ihn sie
müssen sich zusammentun
der böse
die mission ist aufgeflogen
wir brauchen die story ist ziemlich an
den haaren herbeigezogen da geht es dann
um einen virus der die ganze menschheit
vernichten könnte sie müssen dafür auch
noch nach samoa reisen in die heimat von
hawkes das steht eigentlich mich im
vordergrund des films die ganze
geschichte ist ein geplänkel was
eigentlich um diese kampfszenen und
diese verfolgungsszenen herum drapiert
wird wir brauchen autos und waffen
mama war sind die ganzen waffen ich hab
sie entsorgt sehr nobel misstrauens
jetzt haben wir ein richtiges problem
das wassertreten dann eben old school
also ich ganz schön fand war dass man
eben ezer körper wirklich beim kämpfen
sie dass man sie sieht wie sie mit den
mitteln einer frau mehrere relativ
starke große männer zügig und die
daneben an 3 und das sieht man in der
form blanc tief getroffen
gefangen und ich hatte ja relativ
geringe erwartungen an diesem film ich
bin reingegangen und dachte mir das muss
jetzt wohl seinen die nächsten zwei
stunden aber es war dann doch so ich
musste dann zu geben das eine oder
andere mal habe ich schon mich relativ
gut amüsiert es war immer wieder ganz
lustig aber eben auch so eine alberne
art und weise man darf sich glaube ich
nicht allzu viel davon erwarten jetzt
oder nie
ich bin eher der jetzt typ wie du bist
also ab 31
ja wie gesagt niemand was ich tun soll
was man vielleicht am ehesten noch
positiv hervorheben kann ist dass die
rolle von welcher quelle die wirklich
durch geplant war also man kann sich mit
dieser frau identifizieren die ist cool
die ist absolut selbstständig die macht
ihr ding und lässt sich von den männern
die eigentlich eher so lustig alberne
rollen haben gar nicht reinreden
und solang man sich an die hält und sich
ab schaut was man so für kampftechniken
als frau anwenden kann kann man es
glaube ich auch genießen das
filmerlebnis
das ist nicht gut bekommen nach meiner
insel malta
[Musik]
hoffmann